all right welcome back to dc thursday
everyone i'm pete soderling i'm the
founder of data council and the data
community fund
and i'm your guide through the modern
data ecosystem
here on dc thursday we feature
founders of companies leaders of open
source projects
or some type of thought leader in the
data space and today i'm excited that we
have patrick doherty here
who's the co-founder and cto of rasco
and patrick has some interesting ideas
on
data preparation
feature engineering
and recently
on the metrics player as well so we'll
have a wide-ranging conversation about
some of those topics as well as
what patrick sees in the future of data
um so patrick i'm really excited to have
you here thanks for joining us
yeah pete great to be here thanks for
having me
so i just want to let people know a
little bit about your background
as i mentioned now you're the co-founder
of rasco
formerly you were a data science
practice lead at slalom and before that
you were a data scientist at dell
so you've seen you know quite a bit of
uh opportunity in the data science
ecosystem for quite a few years i'm
curious how how did you get into data in
the first place
yeah uh absolutely so started my um
kind of career well in in college i
actually started majoring in industrial
engineering uh loved the idea that every
process could be improved and um that
was sort of the best way to get into
that space at the time felt like the
engineering discipline that was closest
to sort of solving business problems
and
in that role i was
you get exposed to a little bit of data
right industrial engineer has its
engineering has its like roots and data
but you don't get the full fire hose
that we get these days in analytics so
i was first exposed uh through an
internship where i was working as an
industrial engineer
and
i was working on a plant floor which was
um an experience uh it's one of those
things that you kind of do it once and
you learn if you ever if you want to do
it for the rest of your life
um i got to work at a cheez-it plant
actually that was my my kind of first
internship and
it's like the like the little crackers
just like the little crackers
working at this plant where they're
uh churning out like thousands of boxes
per hour of cheez-its and um they taste
way better coming out of the oven i'll
tell you that than they that they do out
of the box
um but it was one of those projects that
i got to work on while i was there
where we're doing time studies which is
like old school industrial engineering
where you're literally looking for you
know trying to squeeze out five ten
second five or ten seconds of efficiency
in like a manufacturing line process
and you know you do that you save 50
grand here 100 grand there over a year
and you know that's how industrial
engineers kind of help improve those
processes
but while i was there we got the
opportunity to do some of those type of
projects
and then there's another project that we
got to
talking about which was
optimizing pack weights so the idea of
how much how many cheeses do i put in
one bag before i seal it up
and there's a lot of math that goes into
that but there's also a lot of guessing
right because you don't know exactly how
big the cheeses are that day and how
much they're gonna weigh so
that sounds like a microsoft it sounds
like a microsoft interview question by
the way
how many jesus can you fit in the ocean
um it does sound like that but it was
one of those weird ones where we start
talking about it and you realize that
right in front of you is maybe the the
single biggest opportunity that they had
from an efficiency standpoint was to
optimize exactly how much you put in
there because
any extras you know wasted
product so
we get into the weeds on that one it's a
pretty obvious like data science problem
right looking back now i realized that
but at the time it kind of felt like
a hopeless exercise right how do you
optimize that
and they weren't even collecting the
data you know this is like the most
important thing they're probably
tracking day to day and they didn't have
a database in place or any way to even
collect that so
it was the first time i um i realized
that yeah i should i should go look into
that more i should see you know that
feels like where things are going is
that we don't have to stand around with
stopwatches we could collect data and
analyze it and then we i asked them you
know if you save a few ounces of cheese
that's going into a box on you know one
production line and you can replicate
that over the whole plant how much money
is that and they're
instantly they said it's five to ten
million dollars in a year if we could
optimize that that packing process so
that kind of stood out to me is like the
first time the power of data becomes
apparent right it's it's scale and the
ability to to scale things across
um you know what humans can't do quickly
yeah right
um and so
so that was sort of early in your career
or you mentioned that was an internship
i know you were also involved in one of
the earliest data analytics programs
master's programs in the country i
believe um tell us a little bit about
that experience
yeah so i was lucky uh growing up in
north carolina the founder of sas
went to nc state my alma mater and
as sas grew and became very successful
he
partnered with nc state to create the
first masters in analytics program
so kind of sas was the first company
that realized that they're going to need
a lot more data scientists to use their
software right as that was going to be
kind of critical to growing the the
company um so they they took a very
active approach and funded the uh the
startup of that program and then i went
through it uh as
i think i was like maybe the sixth class
so it's a 12-month program um so they
had been around for a couple years but i
got to to go through that and um it was
at that point where things were starting
to shift uh data science was getting the
you know sexiest job of the 21st century
you know on the magazine
so starting to get more and more in
demand and um we're fortunate because
the the program was really oriented
toward um you know getting a job in in
uh in the enterprise like not toward a
research progression or sort of an
academic lens it was really geared
toward opportunities in consulting and
then applying new clients at like large
companies
so and you and you ended up doing one of
each of those you did the consulting
thing at slalom and you did the the data
science thing at dell i did yeah uh
opportunity at dell was awesome because
i was my first job out of that master's
program i was
like a solo data scientist that also
had to do some data engineering and
everything under the sun
and that was a great way to start out
because
you know that's the real life of data
science to me is is when you have to
start it like raw data right like
literally getting sent a spreadsheet
sometimes like hey this is the type of
data we can get could you build a model
off of this
um and then you're looking at you know
not just could i train a an effective
model but
could we deploy it right like is the
infrastructure that we could actually do
in production would people use it right
oftentimes humans are still the ones
making decisions with those models so
you know is there the right opportunity
where we could show them what the
model's predicting and enable that human
to make a better decision so
i highly recommend that for people that
are getting into data science like try
and solve a problem from end to end
rather than you know just focus on
building the most accurate model
yeah good advice and what was the state
of data science tooling at the time
it's a great question uh
open source
um
is starting to dominate right so this is
about 10 years ago
uh eight years ago open source is taking
off it's becoming like the
um
python and r are starting to be used for
data science heavily sas is really
starting to die off a little bit already
i would say um because
the sas meaning sas the company yes yes
software as a service yeah
um sas software is dying off because
they uh invested heavily in you know
building for like on-prem hardware
deployments so a lot of times you're
sticking like a sas server box into your
your data center
and uh obviously that's not where the
world went right we went to to the other
kind of sas and hosting things in cloud
um
so yeah that transition was starting but
it's the wild west i mean complete
uh lack of
tooling for for the data scientists to
be more effective i think at the time
there's a couple of of packages out
there um like your data robots were sort
of starting around the same time or
starting to get popular and kind of
approaching it from a different angle
but but certainly
um finding their groundswell
but yeah i would say overall um maybe
similar to software engineering let's
say
10 20 years before that you just it's
really every man for himself for every
woman for them for themselves uh coming
up with the right tools for the job
um and then and then so you transition
from there into consulting i'm curious
um
did you find like what were the biggest
um weaknesses of in terms of sort of
what customers were asking for
um from you know the consultants to to
find in the data or to figure out the
data or what type of insights do they
want to generate that
were difficult or um kind of interested
in in some of the friction that must
have occurred there between a customer
expectation and what you
felt as a consultant you're actually
able to deliver
oh it's it's such a tricky problem
because uh you know the best type of
consulting projects you can easily you
know define the beginning middle and end
right yes those are projects like oh go
implement salesforce right like okay
that's a pretty clear roadmap you get
into a data science modeling project or
ml and it's like yeah we're going to try
some things right and we'll see we'll
see what happens
that's a tougher uh a tougher axe to to
kind of
buy as a as a purchaser of consulting
services so we did a lot of um trying to
to make that more clear and do a lot of
uh pocs initially to validate that
something was predictable or that you
know that there was a
a possibility to build an effective
model there and then come back and look
at like scaling that out to something
that could go into production so there's
a lot of um
crawl before you walk type of deal
but that also led to like really good
trust i would say with the
the um clients that we were working with
because we're very upfront with them we
don't know what we're going to find
right when we get this data in place and
start training models
um but the the time requirements just to
do the pocs where
in my opinion it's just crazy like
mathematically looking at how much time
you have to pay for to get some return
on you know evaluating a model
the the trade-off was
tough because
oftentimes it would take us two to three
months before we could you know source
the right data
centralize it into some type of data
store uh build features train a model
and then evaluate that model in in
these large enterprises that's taking
two to three months no matter the
project
so that was that was a big um indicator
to me that there has to be a way to
uh make that more efficient right like
all these internal teams were doing the
same thing they didn't have any
shortcuts and so you had a lot of data
science teams out there that
were taking
years before they found a really solid
use case right you were able to prove
value on it right
yeah i heard eric colson um who was
obviously formerly head of beta at
citrix and and before that netflix i
heard him say something recently that i
thought was really true in its
simplicity and that's that data
scientists really need to optimize for
learning and exploration it's very
iterative like sort of fast loops of the
faster you can help your data science
team learn the better whereas software
engineers
they're really optimized against
implementing against requirements
definitions and they're really two
completely different
things and
you know maybe back um earlier in your
career
you know the scientists were sort of
unable to
to to work because just getting the data
aggregated together in the first place
was a problem and i think that was very
much phase one of sort of the current
data science era that we're in
um now presumably
you know folks generally have more data
engineers at their disposal or at least
a data-driven tech company has a data
science team and a data engineering team
that sort of work in tandem that's right
um but now that they do i think it's you
know sort of back to eric's first
principles like it's important to
realize that one um implements you know
against requirements definition and one
just really needs to be focused on speed
and
um so i found that you know uh that that
comment quite helpful and it seems like
it's true in your experience as well
very true yeah and i think
underappreciated by
some of the leaders that are managing
both teams right
so they would often come to us and say
how should i how should i manage this
data science team like how do i set you
know
okrs for them and then you know track
them against expectations and it's like
completely differently right than like
you said right the data engineers where
it is culturally like philosophy the
culture of those teams can be completely
different right so different so
different but they have to work closely
together or else they won't produce
value so
how do you split that
right yeah interesting interesting
organizational challenge yes um well so
i wanted to ask you um what was the key
insight that sort of led you to start
rosco
so
working in those consulting uh projects
for our clients getting to work with a
number of companies across verticals i
was working with
coca-cola
uh delta home depot
you're seeing a hospitality like um
intercontinental hotels uh in the travel
industry and you just get this breadth
of
hey if no one has a better way no matter
their industry their tech stack or sort
of their team organization
um that to me is an indicator that
there's a there's a lack of tooling
right there's a way to make these
super talented and smart individuals
more productive
so that was the the genesis for um for
kind of the idea and then really meeting
my co-founder at the right time which
was while i was at slalom
my co-founder jared was working at
domino data lab at the time and seeing
the exact same thing and he was already
seeing it from a vendor perspective
right selling software so it was such a
good uh confirmation for both of us that
we're like
yeah this is a huge opportunity if
someone can help these teams be more
effective so
that was kind of
the uh
the the kick in the pants let's say like
something might be here let's go find
out and then what we did is went out and
interviewed
both both of our networks really and
were very specific with the ask we kind
of met with these data scientists and
said hey here's what we're seeing here's
how we think this could get better if
you had a better
tool or sort of platform that would sit
between you and this data preparation
work that you're doing
um do you think that would you know
mitigate some of that frustration that
you're feeling and um we heard a lot of
yeses just people being like that's a
big problem they were kind of up front
like i'm not sure how you're going to
solve that because
our company is very restrictive about
like where we put data and how that you
know data privacy stuff is set up but
they said if you can you know solve that
that would be go a long way for us being
happier in our job so that was um the
right sign for us to kind of take the
leap
got it so it was really focused around
um
uh providing tooling to help teams um
through their data preparation
challenges and struggles um
what did you what did you think the
early iterations of that tool we're
going to be and how do you think they're
different to where you ended up now
that's a great question
uh it's so much fun going through or
looking back right at the early
prototypes that we had so our very first
hypothesis was uh you'll get a kick out
of this we said um
feature engineering and sort of data
prep is so
time consuming but you have companies
that are all doing it in their own silos
and if you look at it they're actually
feature engineering a lot of the same
types of data right but just doing it
within their four walls so they would
never share that with with others
so he said what if we could build a
feature marketplace where feature
engineering sort of happened once but
then you could almost monetize or share
your features with other companies
and that would unlock so much value on
the modeling side right because you
could sort of go through a shopping cart
and say like i'll take that feature and
that feature and just throw them in
um it was an awesome idea the prototype
was really cool uh you can probably
imagine the first thing we heard like
hey i'm not letting anyone see those
features like those are so valuable
right i'm not ready as an organization
to say that those are something i'm
comfortable sharing with anyone
um which of course makes sense and we we
got there very quickly but it was such a
good uh
it was a great lesson and and you know
back to that security thing like if
you're building a business and in data a
tool for data these days
if you don't have that
answer down right if you can't answer
that question really clearly of like how
does this still enforce security of my
data
um you're in trouble i think that's just
the the state of the world right now
so what is it about data prep that you
think most teams struggle with have you
sort of consolidated a couple key
pains or points in sort of your
exploration over the last several years
on this topic
100
uh there's
let's say there's two key themes that
emerged um number one is the obvious one
to me which is the not reusing code
so there's an idea of i'm going to work
in a notebook
data scientists love notebooks right it
becomes super iterative you can go
really fast
you're building features a lot of times
in like pandas and python so you're
writing code in a slightly abstracted
language but you're often operating on a
sample of data in that notebook
and you'll you know make a couple of
quick uh features you maybe throw them
into like a correlation analysis see if
they're related to your target
that notebook
is
that was the handoff point we were
seeing for a lot of these teams where
they would say oh i checked that
notebook into git someone else can use
it now and it is completely unrealistic
because the next data scientist comes
along they can't get the context they
need from what's in a notebook to
actually trust and reuse those features
and then even if they do want to reuse
the features
you know the data is not there at all
right the data is typically was being
extracted from some other data lake or
data warehouse into the notebook in the
first place
so
doing something like you know refreshing
your feature values
became a whole process that wasn't
answered for in the kind of development
life cycle
so that was the obvious one that was
sort of the first one that we thought
about the second one emerged after we
worked with a lot of users on kind of
that those early prototypes it was
around the idea of trust
it's the idea that
even if i do have someone's code even if
i see the feature values and have access
to them you know in a tool that i could
reuse them
why should i trust them like i didn't
build them data science is not
inherently very collaborative like it's
just it's a it's an exercise that we
often do by ourselves
so
it was very uh sort of foreign to our
users that we would you know that they
would just use their colleagues features
without ever talking to them about it
so that was this other blocker was how
can we surface enough information
that you will as that you know new user
trust what someone else built
um
so those yeah any solution we come up
with that it has to kind of answer for
both of those themes like the technical
the code side and then the sort of
process and context side
and so i think those insights like led
you down this road of really
trying to nail um
an engineering loop around
features and
like how did that how did that go into
what did you learn from that experience
because i think that was sort of
um core to the early
um incarnations of the rest of a product
100 yeah so what we learned is
number one we made a decision early on
we are not going to perpetuate the silos
of data that we keep seeing data
scientists in
so we said anything we build is going to
follow the cloud data warehouse
architecture model where data
centralized in one place not um
siloed in s3 buckets or
different data stores we made a bet on
on snowflake i guess first as kind of
the first data warehouse we would
support and we said what if data
scientists could without even realizing
it just be working in snowflake
alongside where their data engineers are
working
so that was our on on sort of the
technical and the code side that was a
answer that was it was pretty obvious to
us once we went through sort of the pros
and cons
that that was a good decision because
it was bringing that data science team
back into a place where they could be
collaborative with the let's say the
data analysts and the data engineers on
their team
um so
doing that led to
uh okay we know how to centralize some
of the data we know how to make it
reusable we inherit the scale of the
cloud data warehouses which is really
important for data science
we have customers that build features on
40 billion row tables
but they're not because rosco's not
ingesting any of that data it feels very
interactive and ad hoc
even though the um the underlying data
sets in the warehouse are quite large
um and then on the like the people in
the trust side yeah to your point it
became very much about the
let's say the handoff and the the
interaction with other team members
so this idea that once you build
features um you're often doing that like
first you don't have to decide if you're
building something that's going to go
into prod or not we kind of think of it
as you start in like an experimental
capacity
you iterate there um find what works and
you can do that in rosco with
in a in a notebook we still support that
as kind of a an ide
or in our ui if you're if you're less
inclined to want to write the code from
scratch you can use our ui
once you get to something that you're
happy with that you trust that you're
like this is valuable
features that i do want to put into a
model at that point you go through a
publishing process and so that actually
kind of loops you back around to the
data engineer because it says hey here's
here's sql that rosco generated for me
that transforms these features builds
these values out
let's try and put that back into the
prod pipeline because i need this
refreshed on a daily hourly you know
weekly basis um so
using the tool we're kind of enforcing a
workflow there that makes the
organization happy because they're
actually getting that handoff whereas
before roscoe we heard things like
yeah you know three months later i'd get
a jupiter notebook in slack and i would
just have to start from that right there
was no handoff really happening
um yeah that's so interesting um
about sort of the collaboration and the
handoff and how important it is
to have sometimes
you know contracts and
like really define the surface area
between where two different parts of the
value chain or two different teams
really hand off and i know that you guys
have been
quite thoughtful about
um you know a lot of those workflows in
the way that you've built the product
and
i think it's probably generated some
insights that you know maybe surprised
you at times if i'm not mistaken yeah oh
of course
um
the whole the whole journey's a learning
lesson right but uh but no the the big
thing that's come out as we've
kind of implemented that workflow into
the product is the idea that
that's not just useful for data
scientists right that workflow is
something that data analysts are going
through
in a different
headspace sort of with maybe a different
outcome in mind but technically they're
actually doing some of the same things
so what we learned and we learned this
actually about watching how our users
were using the product um and then going
and asking them like hey why are you
doing that
they would kind of say
look they're like rosco is just the
place that i can put
my kind of verified production-ready
data sets like i don't care you know
however someone wants to use that i
don't really care right if they if they
want to train a model with it or if they
want to build a dashboard or god forbid
they want to download it to excel like
that's just you know that's their choice
right as a consumer of that data so they
would tell us um i just send them the
link like i send them the the rosco url
that
it's a link to the data set that they've
built in rosco
so when that person opens it up they can
see
we do this kind of interactive profiling
of the data so you can kind of see what
those value like what that data set
contains
and then you also get the full
transform lineage of how that data set
is built so like all the sql steps that
were used to construct it
are in a canvas view
and so it was really cool once we kind
of heard that enough times that that
that handoff point is so critical we're
adding dbt integration now
to make it really easy for our data
analysts to collaborate with their kind
of data engineer analytic engineers as
well
and have the whole pipeline end up as
something that's running in dbt sql
so that was an awesome insight that came
out of
yeah just kind of listening to the user
and then um
listening to or observing the dvt uh
paradigm becoming kind of ubiquitous
which is awesome
yeah well kudos to you i think you're
you know one of the first companies that
i've seen
um and i've sort of been privately
predicting this for a while that
probably saw clearly the the potential
overlap between the feature store and
the metric store and
um
and obviously those are sort of in two
parallel or like a traditional feature
stores on the ml infratrack in a
traditional metric stores on the
analytics you know data eng track and
i think so far to date we've seen very
few
sort of crossover solutions that sort of
merge
use cases across those discrete
um you know tracks of infra and that's
sort of how we're seeing these point
solutions show up on on either side but
um
i think from you know your perspective
and
listening to the way the users were
using your tool
um you probably stepped into
to some of that you know consolidation
um maybe maybe more quickly than others
i think so and it's funny so we were in
uh vegas for snowflake summit um last
week and and you go
uh you go to a data warehouse conference
and you don't really expect to hear a
lot of like data science talk right or
even data analyst talk you just kind of
expect to be talking to to data
engineers but you show up and um data
robot has a really big booth there and
they're kind of talking about their
snowflake integration and and then in
the keynote one of the big announcements
that they've been working on for a while
is the python support for user defined
python functions surround directly in
snowflake so
some of the that crossover you're
talking about is certainly um
you know might not have really been
possible a few years ago from a platform
standpoint right it could have been like
a user experience that bridged the two
the platform would have had to be
different and i think that that change
is gonna unlock a lot of value um as we
go the next five ten years it's like
data scientists being
the kind of research arm that sits over
in the corner and you don't talk to them
i think that can change now right
because like you said what's the
difference between a metric and a
feature uh there's not much to us i mean
looking at like the the kind of metadata
you need to describe it they are so
similar it's just a matter of
what that end objective is and then with
features you just get a little bit more
abstracted right where a dashboard might
not look at a
13-week lag of a column necessarily
a metric
or a feature engineering you would look
at that for predictive power but
otherwise they're extremely similar kind
of primitive so
um yeah it's gonna be cool to see uh
databricks is going that way google's
certainly going that way with bigquery
more and more data science support
within the data warehouse
yeah i wonder i want to like touch on
this idea of this verified data set
thing because i think it's so
important because it feels like in the
modern data world with data
the data sprawl the etl sprawl
right the data warehouse
you know increased performance
separation of search and compute to be
able to handle the sprawl
i feel like we've gotten into this world
where
um
we don't know lots of about the data
that's going into the warehouse and
um and we've sort of lost control we we
stopped modeling data or someone way
downstream you know has some idea of the
model the representation of that data
but it just gets so lost or transformed
or
munged by so many different systems that
by the time it comes to the data
warehouse
it feels like there's so little trust
from the people who would want to
operate on that data
as to
the providence of the data we talk about
lineage and we talk about you know we've
sort of thrown different terms at this
around this to try and articulate this
problem but
i like this idea of a verified data set
because i think what that implies is
that there's some interstitial
point at which
more intentionality call it a metrics
definition
is sort of you know enforced over that
data to sort of generate a usable
intelligible output for
certain data consumers um you know
inside
inside the data warehouse and that you
can call that a data aster data product
or
a verified data set or whatever um i'm
just wondering if you have
any thoughts on that and because
basically your your tool now it seems
sits in
you know part of the crux of this and
then has the potential to be an ide if
you will for sort of a
you know a final or a verified data
transformation like how do you think
about that that process and that um that
that notion
oh it's funny so i have a mentor that uh
has been in the analytics space for
let's say 25 years and he makes the
point every time i talk to him he's like
remember it's just a pendulum
and what he's referring to is the idea
that uh in the data space we just tend
to oscillate back and forth between
lockdown experiences that are very like
how heavy on the guard rails and
emphasize things like verification like
you're saying in governance
and then you know people get frustrated
with that it goes the other way which is
the kind of data sprawl that you
described right it's like every every
man for himself everyone for themselves
we're just gonna throw all the data out
there and then everyone will go find it
and find inside
and we're certainly i think on the swing
back towards some guard rails right
because in the the hadoop era and then
as snowflake even came in and replaced
hadoop it was still implemented sort of
um generically like you said there's
very little data modeling that actually
happens in the wild these days it's it's
insane so uh that move back to guard
rails
it has a much better chance to sort of
succeed this time i think for for one
reason
it's the idea that um the
the consumption tool the bi tool doesn't
have to be the home for those
standardized definitions
like it did last time right so a micro
strategy of business objects experience
20 years ago was
model it in our tool and then only ever
consume your data through our tool right
it's like the best lock-in of all time
but people inevitably got frustrated and
went around those tools and had to build
things like models that can't go through
that semantic layer
so as we see this opportunity to do more
of the the modeling and the verification
closer to where the data actually is um
which is largely just powered by dbt
honestly it's just the idea that
someone gave us a way to organize those
sql scripts that's a little bit
consistent and not completely ad hoc
um yeah that's unlocked that ability to
have some verification
uh
and that's the
that's the opportunity that that we as
roscoe can take advantage of is like hey
do you know your pipelines as code live
in dbt sql
as you build as those compute and
compile into actual data you know how
can you respect that verification all
the way down to like the user that's
actually consuming the insight right
what's the um the consumption layer for
that verification so so that's where we
fit and it's an awesome place to be
right now and um
we're just getting started i mean that
was uh i saw a post uh coming out of the
snowflake summit that said snowflake
still has 1 40th
of the um the revenues of oracle uh and
that was posted by the ceo
monte carlo and so that goes to show you
like we're this problem is not going
away anytime soon
yeah that's great
um well it's very interesting to see
where you guys have ended up and and i'm
excited about um
the rest of your journey
i'm curious because i wanted to ask you
a couple questions about the future of
data
where do you think we're going to be in
five or so years in terms of data
tooling and infrastructure
yeah
uh it's amazing on the
data science side how much things have
already started to change and i don't
know if we've even realized it yet um
so
the the idea of spinning up a team of
phds or
masters and analytics data scientists
and just saying hey go off for a year
train accurate models and let us know
when you can put something in production
i think that's going to start dwindling
a bit right and the reason is we're
learning about you know through tools
like hugging face we're learning about
this ability to
do more generalized machine learning
where you can kind of train once and
then
infer
with context to specific business
so it just economically won't make as
much sense to do all of the future
engineering and training you know within
an organization i think that starts to
you know continue to move outside of
those four walls
so models as kind of off the shelf apis
that you can hook into that might sort
of learn your context based on your data
it's something that aws has has released
as well with their
personal eyes in their rec their
forecast algorithms
uh that's one trend that i think will
continue because it just mathematically
makes sense that we wouldn't all be
training our own models
um the other thing that that will sort
of necessitate is
that the data scientist becomes more of
a
curator of like experiences and how
these things tie together because if
you're taking a model
off an api endpoint you can call and get
a prediction
how you choose to surface that and how
you choose to explain where that
prediction is coming from i think
becomes way more important right it's
ultimately it just is a black box for a
long time we've been fighting that um i
think we'll kind of stop fighting that
and just start trying to find ways to
to um
explain what's in that black box as much
as you can
so so yeah the idea of like a data
scientist as more of a
a curator or an architect rather than
just a model trainer i think will
continue and then finally
that would just make its way into all of
our experiences right i don't think
we'll have standalone bi tools that
have separate data science you know
layers or integrations like the new bi
tools
they will enrich you know they'll
visually show you what the model is
predicting and what the past historical
data was right there's no reason for
those to be two separate places you have
to go
so as that gets easier more and more
people start using data science
sometimes without realizing it
[Music]
so
so at the end of the day even though
your feature marketplace didn't work
like you're
you're a believer in the model
marketplace and yeah um and and you
think that you know the their their
these models are getting commoditized
and
you know with transfer learning and sort
of other techniques like we'll be able
to capture
like not eighty percent ninety percent
of the value
um of those things without necessarily
building bespoke models and house uh 100
um the
the value the ip is is in the data right
with open source modeling frameworks
the um the ip from developing an
algorithm in-house is dwindling if if
it's still there at all obviously the
big tech company the google facebook
apple the companies that have data that
no one else has or will ever have are
always going to have a leg up in the
type of models they can build
so
they're
very likely i think to expose more and
more of that for um
for monetization right that becomes a
revenue stream for them and like you
said transfer learning is sort of how
the rest of the
the economy can consume that and get
from that um so yeah i i think even if
people don't end up sharing their data
sharing your model is a more secure way
to share your data and the financial
content will be there for for some of
the large ones
well in this in this brave new world and
this this sort of you know future
looking landscape um what do you think
the biggest version is for rasco and and
its products
yeah so uh our mission when we started
out was uh
enable anyone to get insights from data
in less than five minutes
um that was our kind of day one mission
that we came up with and it's funny how
uh much that still sort of rings true
and and honestly how hard that still is
right like you would think with the
advantages or the advances of um bi
tooling that would be at a better better
state with that but you know we've got
amazing dashboard tools they still rely
on a human to build a dashboard right
that there's um this effort you have to
put in to get value from your data so
uh
being at the crux of the like
consumption layer of data
it enables us over time to build more
and more
let's say automated and augmented
experiences around that data
um one example of like a goal for us is
how many questions can we answer
for you as the data consumer without you
ever having to
write a line of code or run a single
transformation on that data right how
many things can we infer
from what we're seeing in that metric
definition and the values of that metric
that we can start to answer those
questions before you ask them because i
think that's where
the 80 20 rule of data should be that we
should spend our 80 on the 20 of the
hardest problems the things that really
do require the
analytical depth and time
but it's that's not what's happening
right now that's not what we're seeing
in the wild we're we're seeing people
spend 80 of their time on maybe like the
the easiest thing the things that should
be sort of obvious right why did this
metric drop yesterday
why did my model accuracy degrade so
let's let's flip that uh over the next
five years and um
you know skip the dashboard right got it
yeah
that's an interesting perspective for
sure
well um patrick it's been great to chat
with you um i i guess just one final
question actually um because i'm always
curious what makes the technical people
um tick when they start companies uh
what's the hardest thing been for you as
a technical person
in being a co-founder of roscoe
the hardest thing has been
translating what we're building into
messaging that can describe it in a
concise period of time
it's uh
i've got so much respect for the great
marketers now that you know i just never
realized how how impossible the task
that is uh if you'll spend 30 minutes
with me we can definitely get into the
weeds on what this thing does right if
you're only giving me 10 seconds that's
right like a really tricky problem so
that's that's not true
that's what um the next company i start
it'll be a lot easier i hope
yeah it gets easier over time believe me
but um yeah that's uh that's the stupid
point and
um it's it takes a gift and i think a
skill um of experience sometimes and
seeing many products to be able to to
articulate things clearly and and cross
that chasm in people's
um you know the mental roadblocks to be
able to explain some of these technical
products in really quick
effective ways so i i definitely have
seen that myself
um well patrick it's it's great to talk
to you i'm really excited about the
company and and the track that you're on
um how can people find you if they have
more questions
yeah roscomml.com uh we just launched
yesterday a free
sql generator which is is cool go to our
blog and you'll see the link to that it
allows anyone to test out our
library of transforms to do things like
target encoding or pivots in sql it's
pretty painful but it's a cool tool that
makes it really easy
very cool awesome well i hope you'll
check that out and
um looking forward to seeing you in
person um in the future um so thanks for
joining us patrick i really appreciate
your time thanks pete
and thanks to all our listeners for
supporting dc thursday we're going to
take a short break for the summer and
look forward to seeing you back here in
the fall so thanks everyone um
enjoy enjoy this episode and all the
other episodes we have on our youtube
channel since